الى غلاف غزه الان مع مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري نجوان اذا ترصد حيث انت
المناطق التي تستهدف ويكثف فيها القصف صفي
لنا ما تشاهدينه
الان نعم محمد القصف متواصل سواء كان من
القذف المدفعي ولكن قبل قليل ايضا نفذ
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي غاره جويه على منطقه
جحر الديك في جنوب شرق مدينه غزه ربما
نستطيع حتى هذه اللحظه رؤيه اثار هذه
الغاره ال الجويه اي وهي ربما الاولى هذه
هذا اليوم او على الاقل منذ ان وصلنا الى
هذه المنطقه صباح هذا اليوم كغيره جويه
تنفذ على هذه المنطقه مع مواصله بطبيعه
الحال القصف المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف
على مناطق مختلفه تنقلنا هذا اليوم من
منطقه الشمال المطله على منطقه بيت حانون
وبيت لاهيه وايضا جباليا
ولاحقا وصلنا الى منطقه مقابله لحي
الشجاعيه واطراف والاطراف الشرقيه ايضا من
مدينه غزه وكان هناك ايضا قذف مدفعي
متواصل وهنا ايضا نرى جزء من حي الزيتون
وحي الشجاعيه
والمخيمات الوسط سواء كان البريج
والنصيرات في بعض الاحيان نرى اثار هذا
القصف المتواصل على هذه المنطقه بسحب
الدخان التي تتصاعد من مواقع ومناطق
مختلفه طيله الوقت هنا
تحليق
للمروحيات العسكريه من نوع اباتشي قبل
قليل ايضا كان هناك القاء
ل او اشتباك بال الرشاشات الثقيله التي
تطلقها هذه المروحيات ايضا لمسانده القوات
على الارض وفي الميدان هذا بالاضافه ايضا
الى تحليق متواصل للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي هذا هو هذه هي الاشتباكات في
ال الرشاشات الثقيله ربما تسمعونها معنا
وهي تحديدا في اطراف منطقه جباليا كما
يبدو
اي او في مناطق شمال مدينه غزه هذا ما
نستطيع ان نرصده من هذا الموقع
المقابل لمنطقه حي
الشجاعيه شرق مدينه غزه والان غاره اخرى
اذا غاره اخرى في مناطق الجنوب كما
تشاهدون معنا هذه غاره جويه
اخرى
للمناطق الجنوبيه تحديدا جنوب منطقه جحر
الدي حيث نفذ سلاح الجو التابع لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل قليل غاره اخرى
اذا هي غارات وقصف متواصل من الجو ومن
المدفعيه طيله الوقت نسمع دوي هذا القصف
محمد من مناطق ومواقع مختلفه ال ال للقوات
المدرعات المحتشد في غلاف غزه على طول
الشريط الحدودي ولكن ايضا هناك غارات جويه
رغم ان
في الايام الاخيره الماضيه كانت قد
اشارت المصادر العسكريه في اسرائيل الى
خفض وتقليل هذه الغارات واليوم نقرا في
صحيفه دعوت احرونوت ان تقليص الغارات
الجويه يرد الى ان الجنود في سلاح الجو او
الطيارين في سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي اخبروا
الضباط في الميدان في ارض المعركه الذين
يقودون المعارك البريه بانهم يخشون من
الحاق الضرر او مساس بحياه الجنود في
الميدان وذلك بعد ان حدث سابقا ان قتل
جنود وفقا لما جاء في موقع دعوت احرونوت
جراء هذا القصف ولكن اللافت ايضا في هذا
العنوان اليوم بان بان الطي الطيارين
يقرون بان تقليص هذه الغارات ابدا لا
علاقه لها بالتخفيف من الاضرار او عدم
المساس بحياه من وصفهم من وصفتهم الصحيفه
ب غير الضالعين
بالقتال من الفلسطينيين وانما فقط لعدم
الحاق الضرر بالجنود وهنا نرى محمد حتى
كلمه الابرياء لا تقولها مواقع او الصحف
الاسرائيليه او حتى ال المسؤولون
العسكريون في جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وانما يطلق عليهم غير الضالعين في القتال
في البدايه كانوا يتحدثون عن ان كل سكان
غزه جزء من هذه المعركه ولذلك اي قامت قام
الجيش الاسرائيلي في المراحل الاولى وما
زال عمليا بقصف كل هذه المواقع هذا اليوم
ايضا كان هناك حديث لاحد المسؤولين
العسكريين اي في الجيش الاسرائيلي مع
اذاعه ال الجيش تطرق فيها الى ان رغم كل
العمليات التي يقوم فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي
سواء كان على مستوى العمليات البريه او
الجويه والقصف من البحر ومن الجو الا انه
يقر بانه لن يكون هناك اي طريقه للقضاء
على قدرات حركات المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
غزه من اطلاق الصواريخ على الجانب
الاسرائيلي تحديدا على منطقه غلاف غزه حتى
بعد نهايه هذه الحرب وهذا اقرار جديد بان
حتى اقل الاهداف التي حددت لهذه الحرب لن
يتمكن الجيش الاسرائيلي من تحقيقها او
انجازها على المدى البعيد احد المسؤولين
العسكريين قال للاذاعه بان صافرات الانذار
ستدوي مجددا في غلاف غزه لان اي ما يقوم
به الجيش الاسرائيلي حاليا من عمليات بريه
قد يمكنه من تقليل اطلاق الصواريخ بعيده
المدى الى مناطق خارج غلاف غزه ولكنه لن
يتمكن من انهاء القدرات الصاروخيه لفصائل
المقاومه تحديدا لحركه حماس من اطلاق
الصواريخ على منطقه غلاف غزه وهذه نقطه
هامه جدا محمد انه بعد ست
ي من هذه الحرب يقول مسؤول عسكري بان هذا
الهدف الذي عرف كا قل اهداف هذه الحرب لن
يتمكن الجيش من تحقيقه شكرا جزيلا لك نجو
سمري من غلاف غزه